[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités une émission
dédiée à celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département
aujourd'hui lundi et 16 janvier parole à
marion jda fils directrice du service
régional unss de versailles elle nous
parlera de la finale du cross national
qui se tiendra le week-end prochain à
saint quentin en yvelines
un événement qui va rassembler près de
2000 participants eux ne jouent pas
encore devant 2000 personnes et
peut-être bientôt au vu de leurs
résultats et jensen le capitaine de
l'équipe senior du sky rugby sera
également notre invité en plateau
on évoquera avec lui le parcours pour le
moment excellent de son équipe mais on
débute donc avec vous marie ange daffy's
bonsoir soit vous êtes donc je le disais
directrice du service régional unss de
versailles où l'académie de versailles
et cette semaine s'annonce donc chargée
pour vous puisque les yvelines et plus
précisément elle
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli la
finale du cross national alors le vrai
nom c'est mgen et unss c'est cross unss
engine 2010 voilà 2017 2000 collégiens
et lycéens sont attendus expliquez-nous
déjà comment se passent les préparations
est ce que vous êtes déjà près ce que
vous êtes en pleine préparation
imaginez vous imaginez mais nous sommes
quand même globalement près avec
quelques quelques finitions bien sûr sur
les derniers jours à effectuer ma
l'horizon pas de problème particulier
tout ça c'est quand même particulier où
on nous annonce une météo froide progrès
dernier ensoleillé ce qui serait quand
même un bon moment alors cette finale se
déroule sur deux jours plusieurs
événements sont prévus on va revenir
dessus mais ce que déjà vous pouvez nous
rappeler pression qui ne savent pas ce
que c'est un cross en quoi ça consiste
comme sport le prof m'a le cross est
tout simplement une course sur un
terrain sur les terrains variés terrain
technique avec des montées et des
descentes des vétérans particulier en
course à pied ont rappelé leur sa pièce
panique moss n'en ont pas du luxe et de
la presse à billets et de la course à
pied c'est une des activités majeures de
l'urss alors au programme vendredi du
côté du vélodrome il ya une journée
découverte et santé qui est organisée
est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus sur cette journée là c'est au
vélodrome nationale c'est pas là donc on
a vraiment deux temps distinctes dont un
qui sur le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines où nous allons
accueillir cette fois ci des élèves de
la communauté de saint quentin à peu
près 1200 élèves de cold écoles et des
collèges dans le cadre d'une course
solidaire basé sur la santé c'est un
parcours santé
wen santé parcours santé défie les lois
là précisément à ces modifications il y
aura aussi un village santé de la santé
avec des animations alors un événement
évidemment qui est qui représente
l'ouverture de la semaine de l'olympisme
dans le cadre de l'olympique de l'école
à l'université qui a été instaurée par
le ministère des sports
donc c'est la première événement qui va
ouvrir cette semaine de leur accord donc
cet événement vélodrome évidemment on va
accueillir les élèves dans un écrin qui
est le vélodrome the savage et qui est
un site officiel de la candidature de
paris 2024 du coup les élèves pourront
éventuellement il y aura des baptêmes de
cyclisme il y aura des baptêmes de bmx
les animations voilà des démonstrations
de l'équipe de france juniors donc
vraiment une grosse fête pour ses et
pour les élèves de l'agglomération dans
un premier temps alors j'imagine que le
but c'est aussi de faire de la pédagogie
auprès des plus jeunes sur l'importance
de de faire du sport voilà les nouvelles
générations les plus jeunes mais ce qu
il comprenne ça sans s'en soucier
ils comprennent si on les met en
pratique il n'ya pas de y'a pas de
soucis mais l'idée c'est de comprendre
qu' on a besoin d'une pratique régulière
et notre un de nos objectifs majeurs de
nos axes majeurs c'est la découverte de
la découverte l'apprentissage de ces
décès de cette démarche et à travers les
plus jeunes on peut après éventuellement
toucher les parents aussi les parents
exactement c'est on est vraiment dans la
pédagogie comme vous dites
la finale aura lieu elle le samedi le
lendemain ça rien à vous alors voilà
c'est vraiment la finale du championnat
de france où des élèves qualifiés de
toutes les académies de france ce qui
fait venir personne de la voilà mille
sept cents coureurs mais c'est à peu
près 300 accompagnateurs pour leur
professeur d'éducation physique et du
coup qui viennent de la france entière
voilà de tout un academy donc à sur une
course mixte des lycées des collèges et
une course de sport partagé qui est une
course qui quittent y associer des
élèves en situation de handicap avec des
élèves valides
alors c'est à dire une forme
particulière de relais qui voit là c'est
une course qui fera l'ouverture de ce
cross 21 était de faire passer un
message peut-être auprès des jeunes de
regarder le handicap autrement
différemment et palace elle aussi voit
la parole est un des axes un des axes de
l'urss c'est de montrer justement que le
sport c'est accès pour tous tout le
monde peut accéder et là en même temps
notre l'idée de de sport en équipe plus
que l'urss ont fait peu de l'activité en
équipe
donc c'est vraiment une démonstration
type pour que nos élèves soient
sensibilisés aux sports de questions
encore là notamment une question sur on
voit on voit des noms dans le communiqué
de presse qui sont sous mes yeux moyens
lorthiois la mise en place il va secouer
les stars de la télé l'audi nouvelles
révélations
d'ailleurs il en décrivant tous notre
ambassadrice et qui sera là dès le
vendredi qui participe pas même sur
l'atelier pentathlon puisque c'est une
médaille et doriot en pentathlon moderne
donc nous aurons ladji doucouré et
muriel hurtis dimitri bascou samir
dahmani qui seront des ambassadeurs qui
viendront sur le samedi pour battre pour
encourager tous nos jeunes allié au plus
loin de leur capacité une dernière
précision peut-être sur le volet
interactif et moderne de la compétition
puisque le cross sera retransmis ça
c'est plutôt étonnant elle en direct sur
le site urss et son orgue la page
facebook
voilà donc pourquoi j'aimerais partir
loin bon alors mais tous avec des haches
takraw suez né cesse pour être tous
connectés
il y aura un plateau télé
et on pourra prendre un petit peu en
direct les émotions des élèves après
leur course avant leur course enfin
vraiment ça permettra vraiment d'avoir
une dimension on va dire plus que
national mondial international nous
encourageons tous à se connecter sur la
steg cross unss
merci beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
au rappel de google cross national c'est
les 20 et 21 janvier 2010 et à saint
quentin en yvelines et on peut avoir
toutes les précisions directement sur le
site internet unss point org
merci marie ange mercie bien peu venu on
poursuit cette émission avec etienne
seigle bonsoir vous êtes le capitaine du
sky rugby sky ps qui ont dix cailloux
skikda et rugby l'équipe seniors à du
sky rugby évolue en promotion d'honneur
on va voir tout de suite peut-être
l'infographie pour le classement est à
mi saison où vous êtes premier de votre
championnat avec un bilan assez
impressionnant 7 matches gagnés pour un
seul de perdus on peut parler d'un bilan
parfait ou plutôt presque parfait s'il y
est parfait ou presque parfait vous
voyait presque parfait parce qu'on
essaie de petite défaite qui fait tâche
alors là on voit les noms des équipes
c'était contre triel les mureaux à triel
donc un concurrent direct pour la montée
ouais c'est un concurrent pour la montée
on le savait dès le début de saison
après c'était chez eux au match aller on
a perdu on a perdu parce qu'ils ont très
bien joué on a moins bien joué que
forcément soulor comme ça
comment vous expliquer une telle
dynamique même s'il ya une défaite du
coup vous lisiez mais il ya quand même
une excellente dynamique et mise en
route
c'est dû à quoi un groupe sain
entraîneur
le groupe est sain
les entraîneurs les entraîneurs
interagissent bien avec le groupe ça se
passe plutôt bien et même très bien
ils sont arrivés ils se réveillent à 3
ans kai donc ça se met en place
j'imagine sans ça le message est rentré
ouais ça se met en place et on essaie on
essaie d'évoluer au fur et à mesure on
essaie de on renforce nos points forts
on travaille sur nos points faibles et
ça se passe plutôt bien
forcément à mi saison qu'on voit un tel
classement cinq points d'avancé sur le
deuxième et troisième vous avez même 17
points d'avancé sur le quatrième
est-ce qu'on se sent pas un petit peu
intouchable est ce que justement c'est
pas ça le piège se reposer sur ses
lauriers ça peut être les pieds surtout
que surtout quand on occupe la place de
leader forcément à chaque fois qu'on se
déplace au cours son équipement on est
l'équipe on peut accrocher ou abattent
en fait ouvert à tous les tableaux ouais
faut toujours faut toujours être
meilleur de match en match et ce qu'on
essaie de faire et ça se passe plutôt
bien pour l'instant
alors l'objectif c'est forcément la
montée avec un tel classement c'était
déjà l'objectif en début de saison alors
vous êtes surpris par par l'ensemble de
vos résultats
c'était l'objectif déjà la saison
dernière on est passé à côté d'eux peut
s'écouter de pleurer et c'est l'objectif
annoncé dès le début de saison c'était
l'objectif annoncé
tous les joueurs est partagé est ce que
le fait d'avoir loupé la montée de peu
l'an dernier ç'a finalement ça joue en
votre faveur cette saison ce qu'on
apprend de cet échec et et on est encore
plus motivé quand la nouvelle saison
commence en asie pas une deuxième fois
bah forcément on apprend toujours un peu
dans la défaite aussi la victoire c'est
toujours plus simple mais alors on est
passé vraiment vraiment pas très loin de
la montée l'an dernier il ya peu de
frustration en fin de saison et on a
bien attaqué le début de saison ça nous
a servi parce qu'on
on a conscience qu'on pouvait le faire
que le groupe pouvait le faire et cette
année on va essayer de tout faire pour
aller jusqu'au bout et décrocher cette
montée alors vous aviez normalement un
match ce week-end vous ne l'avez pas eu
finalement ça a été annulé pour aux
conditions on va dire climatique
météorologiques
ouais le comité fermer tous les terrains
et nous lie tous les matches en ile de
france
c'était contre noisy le dernier du
classement est ce que débuter la phase
retour contre le dernier le placement
pour se remettre en route c'est pas
aussi est-ce que le calendrier n'est pas
parfait aussi pour vous ce que c'est pas
calendrier idéal ou alors c'est le match
piège
ouais je sais pas s'il ya vraiment des
matchs aux pieds jouent des matches
idées ou des calendriers vidéo mais s
arrêter sur été une bonne reprise ou
après après la petite coupe l'eau après
un petit rêve on a joué on allait jouer
un match en retard
le week-end dernier déjà en course et
termine s'est-il remis un peu dans la
boue et dans la pluie c'est difficile de
se remettre après les après les fêtes
c'est la machine est relancée à 100% en
plus on imagine que bon et rugbyman
mange bien pendant les fêtes c'est le
cas on imagine ça on sait pas si c'est
moi mais ouais mais comme tout le monde
après plus ou moins salée pour un coût
de chacun on n'a pas un programme
spécifique pour les fêtes non plus on a
fait pas mal de physique avant le avant
la trêve pendant la trêve dans le débit
très blanc fin d'année 2016 et du coup
on rattaque et 2017 et en ayant envie de
rejouer à ce qu'elle est très bien peu
long quand même et on a hâte de
retrouver le terrain c'est pour ça qu'on
s'entraîne un mot sur le calendrier pour
terminer vous commencez on va dire par
des équipes de milieu de tableau pour la
phase retour puis à la fin de saison
sera les les gros les deuxièmes et
troisièmes ceux qui peuvent encore vous
dire vous empêcher de monter que ce sont
les deux premiers enfin le premier de
chaque poule qui va monter l'an prochain
c'est à ce moment là que ça va jouer ça
veut dire que d'ici là vous êtes dans le
calcul ou alors vous jouez tout à fond
quitte à peut-être prendre des risques
en termes de blessures d'usure physique
avec le temps après en terme de calcul
s'est jamais trouvé de calculer en
disant que ça soit en bus faire un peu
l'impasse et et l'autre on se donnera à
fond parce que on l'a vu à n'importe qui
peut perdre chez n'importe qui a pas
vraiment de premier au dernier
les matchs om
vraiment jouer à l'avant surtout notre
niveau tout peut basculer sur un petit
détail un fait de jeu et non non on joue
tous les matches pour aller gagner pour
aller chercher les points de bonus pour
pour finir premier et tranquille à la
fin de saison n'a pas joué une montée
sur un dernier match sur une
hypothétique victoire d'un autre de la
poule une défaite et c'est de garder le
garder de notre destin en main et tout
faire pour tout gagner
une dernière question sur sur le rôle
quand on est une équipe
une comme ça premier avec tant de points
d'avancé quel est le rôle de l'équipe 2
qui sait quel est le rôle justement de
l'équipe de c'est d'être toujours à fond
à l'entraînement pour que vous aussi
vous restiez sous pression quel est le
rôle de l'équipe de bons à l'équipe 2 c
c'est pour moi c'est surtout un s'est
surtout attelé via pas vraiment une
équipe mais une équipe 2 c'est un vrai
groupe
ya pas vraiment de place attitrée en
équipes une en équipe 2 forcément à des
joueurs qui jouent beaucoup plus sur
première co réserve après on s'entraîne
tous ensemble on aimait mes
entraînements si si on veut avoir une
équipe le plus compétitif possible faut
que tout le monde soit arrivé au même
niveau et tire vers le haut merci
etienne seigle d'être venu en plateau
prochain match pour vous le 24 janvier
on sera séchée vous en plus à 15 heures
donc on peut se rendre pour vous voir
éventuellement à gagner merci d'être
venus en plateau tous les deux c'est la
fin du set 8 et les invités pour ce soir
prochain rendez vous demain mardi 17
janvier excellente soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]